a bee is not here today right so here's
the bottom line he's upset about the
helmet issue we've worked very closely
with the Raiders and we will continue to
work very closely with the Raiders we
have supported that we appreciate that
okay but we've at this point we've
pretty much exhausted all avenues of
relief I am Not sure that we agree that
we've exhausted all the options from our
perspective it's time for him to be all
in we're all out there's no doubt it's
still an ongoing process we're hoping
he's back soon
we got 89 guys busting their tails I
wouldn't make too much about him not
being there today we are really excited
about where this franchise is going and
we hope a bee is going to be a big part
of it starting week 1 against Denver a
little mike Mayock a little Drew
Rosenhaus and a lot of uncertainty as to
where this relationship stands between
receiver Antonio Brown and the Oakland
Raiders it could be it could be an NFL
marriage that doesn't last very long and
even if it somehow makes it into the
season and through the season Chris it's
starting to feel like it's not going to
last into 2020 so it could be a
short-term deal so for today's pft live
draft we're gonna look at NFL marriages
that end it quickly now we've gotten rid
of the rigged coin toss thank God for
that we moved on to a rigged Twitter
trivia question right today I get to ask
the question you get to answer the
question and the question is this
during Antonio Browns extended career
with the Pittsburgh Steelers how let me
I'm gonna screw this up
sorry control room I'm doing it my way
give me the over/under on the number of
quarterbacks that have thrown Antonio
Brown touchdown passes the over-under is
2.5 wait a minute what's right or wrong
here oh you got to get it right
over/under is it 2.5 man you really
screwed that up I think we need to go
back the coin toss this guy can't even
but I think we do need okay here's the
problem when I'm informed of the trivia
question three minutes before the
segment start
to create some issues but go ahead you
guys are in trouble in the back he's mad
about this alright so I'm going to say
I'm gonna go with the over just because
Big Ben's been banged up a little bit
and you're wrong
he's the only one listen there they
thought that it was a trick question and
you'd fall for it if I had you just
named all the quarterbacks but it's like
wait a min you can't name all the
quarterbacks you're not gonna remember
them all
as he was suspended he's been as you're
not gonna remember all you can say it's
a trick question Roethlisberger but two
and a half I knew I'd get you to take
the over you know you one or two that I
couldn't think of I thought maybe a
Landry Jones at least threw him one and
then there would be somebody out there
there was a little Mike Vick in there
surprise that's a good one I like that
alright now I get the first pick and I
don't know what I'm gonna do hmmm I
gotta go I gotta go with the ultimate
short-term NFL marriage
Bill Belichick yeah the HC of the nyj
for one day
that's what is that is that an annulment
I mean he showed up at the altar he took
the vows he signed a contract and then
he got a cocktail napkin and he wrote on
it I want a divorce and he left that's
the that's the ultimate short NFL
marriage Bill Belichick once was indeed
the head coach of the New York Football
Giants and you know you see all the
personality Bill Belichick had at the
time charisma all that that's all gone
out the window he doesn't care anymore
he's got rings and trophies and he says
the hell with you this day and age but
yeah I mean that was the obvious number
one pick there I gotta say that I mean
I'm gonna go with one a little bit along
the same lines but it didn't even get to
the contract signing part but I gotta go
with John Elway with the the Baltimore
Colts at the time okay I mean is that
you know John Elway gets drafted number
one overall he kind of lets it be known
I'm not gonna play for you nonetheless
they still draft him and yes it was a
marriage that ended very quickly John
Elway threatened to play third base for
the New York
Yankees the Colts kind of dug their foot
feeding the ground for a little bit but
then eventually said okay the hell would
this and traded him to the Denver
Broncos but that was one of the quickest
marriages in the NFL that I certainly
remember at least a publicity around
that I don't know if it necessarily
totally fits in with Antonio Brown and
all that which I got more coming up but
I just had to take that one because I
thought it was kind of a big deal yeah
but but it wasn't really a marriage
because he never went to the altar he
never took the vows it was unrequited it
was it was an arranged marriage and the
bride did so it was Bill Belichick it
was an array he had Agron oh now you got
do your research Christopher he had
signed the contract that would make him
the head coach of the team he had
already agreed that that was what was
gonna happen and he didn't like that
being foisted upon him that way he was
the coach of the team he did not say I
don't want to be he wasn't any resign he
had signed the dough he signed the
contract are you sure about that he had
signed the contract he was under
contract the Patriots had to compensate
the Jets in order to get him away right
when he left to go to them so yeah it's
try to trust me it works he there was a
marriage there there was no marriage
with John Elway and the Baltimore Colts
so you've already blown it alright I
have I have one that actually lasted a
year but it was the second year that it
fell apart so it's Deion Sanders and
Washington and I guess more specifically
Deion Sanders and Marty Schottenheimer
because Sanders what you know the big
high-profile free-agent acquisition one
of the guys that was pushing Washington
over the top in 2000 they ended up
failing and not making it to the
playoffs Norv Turner got fired as the
head coach Marty Schottenheimer comes in
as the head coach and Deion Sanders
quits during training camp because he
doesn't want to have any part of
Oklahoma drills he don't have anything
to do with Marty Schottenheimer he hit
and he had gotten that huge signing
bonus
they didn't make him pay it back he
agreed to retire from football so he
didn't play for anybody else
so it's Deion Sanders and Washington
slash Marty Schottenheimer even though
he played there for a year it was a
disaster in 2001 and by the way
Schottenheimer would be fired after his
only year as head coach of the team yeah
it was a disaster I mean that whole
thing was shocking the amount of money
they gave Deion I think at that point in
time where you know again it
Deon's one of the greatest I've ever
seen but certainly at that point of his
career in that age he was not in the
Dion we had come to known in the early
90s and mid 90s when he was helping lead
the Cowboys and 49ers to the Super Bowl
but yeah that was that was ugly
certainly and I remember that so that
was on my list as well I'm gonna go with
one that was really even worse than that
okay maybe this guy's not to the caliber
a player but this guy was a Super Bowl
MVP and played with Deion Sanders and
that's Larry Brown that you want to talk
about a marriage that was a disaster or
a marriage that was you know all kind of
like predicated off of a one-night stand
do you like that you know yeah but it
was one night in Super Bowl 30 where
Larry Brown had two interceptions and
won an MVP and the Raiders gave him
money and he goes in there to Oakland
and what he only plays starts one game
in his career there with the Oakland
Raiders and really only plays in 12
games overall but that was an NFL
marriage where it would look cool when
it first happened and you thought oh
gosh Larry Brown's gonna help out this
Raiders football team and he did nothing
and it kind of ended up being a bust
type situation all right that one's that
one is okay I you know I have so many
yeah and I thought I was gonna have to
use some more obscure ones but you you
you you've left some of the most obvious
ones still on the board and I don't know
what I want to choose from here but I'm
gonna go with one specific player and
and when I say Terrell Owens which team
do you think I'm gonna say I mean it
could be any of them really it could be
all of them
yes you would assume I'm gonna say the
Philadelphia Eagles I was there for a
year Lucas won right no I'm going with
Terrell Owens in the Baltimore Ravens Oh
because Terrell Owens was traded to the
Baltimore Ravens in 2004 and he fought
it he filed a grievance and the end
result was he got traded to the Eagles
instead of got traded to the Ravens and
the Ravens got some compensation along
the way so he was technically a member
of the Ravens for a very short period of
time
in March of 2004 and it altima worked
out for tio because he was
back tacular that year in Philadelphia
they went to the Super Bowl but yes he
was a member of the Baltimore Ravens for
a brief period of time 15 years ago and
a very short marriage one that never saw
him wear a helmet or a uniform but he
was on the team yeah I guess so I mean
that's boring no to even remember it's
not that good if I can't remember it
it's great
I mean Belichick was signed on is that
just a coach he wasn't a head coach I
challenge all emotes oh come on I'm
going on Albert Haynesworth okay Albert
Haynesworth you want to talk about first
off I played with Albert Haynesworth in
20 and 2008 he was up to that point into
2008 like the most dominant defensive
player in football he was unblockable
you'd want to talk about s the play up
right Mike I mean he was F and plays up
every F and play okay I mean that's how
good he was he goes to Washington gets a
hundred million dollar contract and just
became nothing he was a shell of himself
from that point on added to the fact
that yes it only lasts two years with
the Washington Redskins but just like
you do I'm gonna add a little more to it
he goes to New England and we all go Oh
New England got themselves a steel oh
gosh to where you know Bill Belichick I
think I got a guy I don't even need to
see him play in the preseason he's gonna
be phenomenal it's Albert Haynesworth I
had to deal with this guy a few years
ago and Tennessee when when it doesn't
work out there either and that was
really the end of Albert Haynesworth all
together so that would be up there as
far as NFL marriages that ended quickly
he got that gigantic money in 2009 Jim
Zorn was the coach then started 12 games
appeared in 12 games it was when Mike
Shanahan came and changed the defense
from a 4-3 to a 3/4 I don't want to be a
nose tackle right and it just went off
the rails he had zero starts in 2010
gray appeared in eight games his only
season there with Mike Shanin a couple
others real quickly that I considered
Brett Brett Farve in the Jets it was a
one-year marriage that fell apart how
about Bobby Petrino coaching the Atlanta
Falcons and walking out in December I
had his particular I just didn't want to
do a coach I wanted to try to keep it to
players in a bunch of pot George Allen
how about the great George Allen I
didn't realize when I'm looking this up
he coached two preseason games to the
right
in left town so that was a good one how
about how about this one how about this
one
there once was for like a day or two a
team known as the Los Angeles Seahawks
in 1996 they moved to Seattle until the
NFL said we're gonna find you $500,000 a
day until you move back they quickly
moved back I do not remember that that's
that was a new one to me okay I also had
like nan de awesome wah on there I had
Matt Flynn on there okay and then I had
Lane Kiffin and Reggie Wayne also on
there too with Reggie Wayne and his two
weeks at training camp with the New
England Patriots before he realized it
wasn't as fun as Indianapolis and he
wanted out of there yeah you know a lot
of a lot of guys late in their career go
to go to New England thinking they're
gonna get a ring and realize no no no I
don't want to do what I have to do to
get that ring because it isn't fun it's
fun when you get the ring alright I got
the ring for this one
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports